at this point in the film malcolm has
come home from the
premiere of his film in which he forgot
to thank his girlfriend
five years marie and
we just found out that the movie he
wrote also happens to be based on her
and essentially
during an argument that they have she
ultimately kind of disappears and he's
searching
you know through the house for her where
the [ __ ] you go
to pee so where outside
why didn't you just use the bathroom
because i didn't grow up with a backyard
and the novelty hasn't worn off yet
this scene where he he comes upon her in
the kitchen here
you are the neediest man i've ever dated
i think this is probably
take 27 not not because of performance
issues but
uh but merely because of of the blocking
of it so
this is something we we all kind of work
together to figure out what seemed
natural
what could create movement how you two
could kind of circle each other i think
that was a a part of it was
you know you see these this couple who
loves each other very much
is having a very difficult evening and
we know a fight is coming
but we don't know who's going to throw
the first the first blow
but whose arm are you hanging that's the
thing it doesn't really matter is this
about tonight marie
kinda i think
marie uh is aware that she's starting
something here
you know how do i get into that with her
not just being like
attacking him you know but um but he was
like well it's genuinely inquisitive
like she really is thinking like
you know i walked around i'm gone for
like 30 seconds and you're
yelling my name throughout the house
trying to find me
kinda when we find malcolm to open the
scene
he's already triggered you know because
of her past and her
what she's overcome what he's been with
her through
and so it's interesting like burying
that and
with the more questions she's starting
to pose you see him motivated again
when he goes he goes to get his drink
and i think it's to really fuel up
you know because something's a brewing
something's happening we're not out of
the woods
malcolm you can encourage me to have a
life of my own but that's just
that's [ __ ] you don't actually want
me to have a life that is separate from
yours because you are too [ __ ] needy
i thought we were done fighting don't be
sensitive this isn't a fight yeah
right it's not it's an observation
oh you don't want to go there why is
that trust me you don't why is that
because
even if you do you're not thinking
clearly i think i'm thinking clearly
trust me you're not
huh well i do have a slightly
masochistic streak but you're not
dumb oh my god thank you don't be a
[ __ ] and don't [ __ ] patronize me
and tell me i gave up something when you
know damn well your work is all that you
have time for and all you [ __ ] care
about oh so you gave up a [ __ ] career
in acting to be an emotional [ __ ]
support dog
my favorite moment in this entire like
fight sequence is when jd is following
you around the bar
back into the bedroom uh and i think you
hit z you hit marcel's shoulder a little
bit
and the camera bumps and then jd comes
too close to the camera
as marcel is trying to back up into the
bedroom and
but as an actor jd doesn't stop he just
keeps going and the messiness of it
is what gives it that life it's what
it's what
makes it feel honest and real and by
morning you're drinking on zany's
trying to [ __ ] cut your wrists with a
pair of [ __ ] nail scissors
stupid [ __ ] malcolm i want you
to leave this room oh shut the [ __ ] up
marie
you know i get it i really do you have
pain and [ __ ] disappointment and
dreams
like everybody else on planet earth
you're mad that you didn't get the jobs
you wish you got
you're embarrassed that you had to play
skinny girl in alley and concern nurse
number two well guess what
none of us are proud of when we first
start off
there's there's similar sort of
bearing the undercurrent you know
posturing almost like there's something
like it gets it gets blown out when he
when he like even in this moment here
all the things
that he says but then he's trying to get
it like back together or act like he has
it together like he's the mature one
you know when in fact maybe he's not but
you do have to
work harder than 99 of people
you know what's [ __ ] what's a
[ __ ] cop-out marie is you
acting like my work is so [ __ ]
suffocating that you can't even breathe
that you don't have
any [ __ ] space i mean look around
look at this [ __ ] house
the production company put us up in pick
a room
get the [ __ ] work and stop blaming me
for your inability to get your [ __ ]
together
just i've just noticed that he was like
this facial thing he does
it's posturing you know he's faking it
you know what really he's trying to
suppress but he's faking it looks like
he's
he's posing you know and uh i think that
was on that seemed to be on purpose
because she's starting to reveal some
truths his special expressions his
mandarins all that kind of starts to
change and come to surface
when you relapsed i was there for you
when we lived on 38th street
and you went out to that meeting right
you went to the meeting
and you didn't come home because you
were [ __ ] somebody else right
guess who was there for you this [ __ ]
right here
so don't go there do not
[ __ ] go there because you are not
gonna win this one marie
trust me
i just want to point out that in
brilliant take that you had
that all of us knew was going to be the
one
that i also recorded on my phone and we
played every day on set
because i mean the way he ended it and
he pointed at her and he didn't come
home
because you were oh and then he added
his little thing at the end i said you
better go ahead john david
you better give us a performance give me
fuel to
to try to be beat you down in the next
scene
because no i'm going to give you that
much feel because like you really
it was an iconic moment for all of us on
set i would say
and i think this is this is why just
from uh
from a filmmaking perspective i
struggled with
with how how to shoot and capture each
scene because
there was such a raw energy that was
coming out between the two of you
that any fixed ideas i had about how
this would be
shot oh so this is you know let's just
be this should be a lock off this should
be dolly
kind of all went out the window um for
every scene
and we just had to kind of adapt as a
crew
to what you two were bringing and and
honestly the kind of the lightning in a
bottle that was
being captured between the two of you
because it felt so
real so raw um
and uh we were just doing everything we
could to not
miss one one frame of this performance
it's crazy too how uh malcolm is lit in
that moment when he's almost like
like as he's digging in like he's he's
getting lower to dig
and like there's this like shadow of
like anger that's following him that you
can literally visit like you can see
through the angle of the camera which
was interesting and i remember remember
when
we i go to the bar and there was some
stuff that was really happening that we
didn't plan for
now just to your point i remember you
coming around the bin
like getting marcel like
like but we were still going we were
still shooting it was that was
that was an interesting moment though no
because that performance
unlocked something within you that was
just fascinating and you walked out of
the room but i could
hear i could hear you so i go running
out and i was like trying to
guide marcel through the door frame and
this thing and i'm just going get him
get him you know
yeah go back out go right into it you
know i remember us also trying to figure
out
how she was going to enter the scene
because he had just
given this beautiful dynamic performance
and
she's sitting in the room and we were
all just trying to figure out well how
the hell
is she gonna get back out out there
all right how about we cut the [ __ ]
malcolm
is everybody's being [ __ ] honest
tonight how about you be honest
huh about the real reason you were there
for me
for her it was just to have that respect
to have that thank you marie thank you
for all that you do because i would not
have been able to create this movie
without you and that's really i think at
the base of it all she wanted
that's i think how i relate to it and
how it relates in the sense of this
whole movie
in a meta on-screen off-screen kind of
way
and i've never been loved the way you
love me or thought you loved me i didn't
realize what i was to you
a [ __ ] movie a tragedy
one that you can continue watching for
as long as you were there for me and
tonight
[ __ ] audience i watched the whole
[ __ ] play out so don't pretend like it
was a selfless [ __ ] act malcolm
is literally the basis of your art and
it is the reason why all these people
are calling you brilliant
and brave and fearless we did it a lot
of different times in a lot of different
ways
and it was one of those kind of like
creative battles of like i wanted to do
it really soon
you wanted to do it like super you know
up there and then somehow
we kind of found this beautiful thing in
the middle
well jennifer that's a good question i
guess you could say i
stole it i ripped it off
not a literal theft a spiritual one
marie is interesting
she clearly has a backstory she's been
through some [ __ ]
but she is now a brilliant actress very
smart
and capable and methodical
but also she's very emotional but she's
also very in control
of her emotions she can decide when she
wants to cry and when she doesn't when
she wants to break
and when she doesn't she knows all of
malcolm's triggers all the things that
drive him crazy
and i think from the moment they step in
to the home
i think she's in control of the whole
night you don't have
the balls you don't have the gravitas
the [ __ ] introspection to look at
yourself
and your flaws and your shortcomings and
the fact that you may not be the next
spikey or barry jenkins because those
[ __ ] had something new to say
something true to themselves and their
[ __ ] experience
you say that the film is about shame and
guilt
correct your words not mine
all right well i have a question for you
malcolm whose [ __ ] shame
whose guilt what the [ __ ] do you know
about shame and guilt
you have two parents no bad habits other
than being a [ __ ] prick and a college
education
your mother is a therapist your father
is a professor your sister works for a
think tank
in dc but out here on these streets
these smiling [ __ ] rich people they
think you know what it's like
to scrap think you [ __ ] lived it
give me a break
you're more privileged than the white
girl who works for the la times who
thinks she's doing a public service
by lifting up your mediocre ass
now you're being cruel this almost this
event sequence like this is an event in
their lives and how he
covered it sort of tells the back story
in a way
and it's just the perfect marriage of
what you wrote and what cindy has
given us it just matches up so perfectly
i love that
it's embarrassing and it's cruel and it
makes me regret sharing so much with you
[ __ ]